hey what's up everyone welcome to
another hd tutorial from mkbhd and this
one i'll be showing you guys how to
download and install tweetdeck
so basically tweetdeck is obviously a
twitter client um if you haven't used
twitter before my twitter link is on my
page you can uh follow me on twitter to
get basically exclusive updates when i'm
uploading a video when i'm when i'm away
stuff like that so um basically go to
any major search engine you can aol
yahoo google anything like that and type
in tweetdeck and it will be the first
link there tweetdeck.com
once you click on tweetdeck.com it'll
take you to the beta website it's
version 0.2.5
and i basically just hit the download
now button it is free is a very full
version and it runs on the adobe air
platform for mac os 10 for windows and
for linux
so here we go it'll open up the adobe
application install um you're going to
have to install and allow everything and
just hit continue and if uac does pop up
just hit continue
so yeah we're going into the
installation process here it's
installing the application and as it's
doing this i'll talk a little bit about
tweetdeck it is it has a big it's a
really nice powerful and fast uh twitter
client um it does have facebook
integration so you can update your
twitter status uh thr or your facebook
status through here so um now that has
been fully downloaded and installed i'm
going to exit out of our web browser and
what we can do see we've got an icon on
our desktop and first thing it does is
open up tweetdeck
so here's what it looks like
all right let's wait for it to finish
actually i'm not signed in but um i'm
just going to uh see this icon here i am
signed in so here's what it looks like
when you're fully signed in obviously i
have a ton of messages and replies and
stuff i'll just click on it
so i
um
a tweetdeck is a really full-fledged
twitter client right now i have three
columns open the all friends uh people
who i'm following whatever you want to
call them those are all their updates in
the middle i have replies so people who
have replied at mkbhd
and on the right hand side are all the
direct messages
so um if you have were wondering why i
haven't answered any direct messages
because i was i uninstalled tweetdecks
to do a redo
i'm doing a tutorial on it so i'm just
going to minimize it here and it does
minimize to the system tray and i see
this icon here on our desktop we're
going to want to put that up in our
communications tab somewhere next to
skype all you got to do is just drag it
in
so there we go
and it's it's in the communications
folder now a lot of people say well i
want tweetdeck to start um with my
computer kind of like a i am used to
all you have to do is take the tweetdeck
icon drag it to the start menu
uh hold it hover it over all programs
and you have to go and just drag down
all the way until you get to the startup
folder and the startup folder is where
you have all the things that um that
start with windows so like uh maybe you
have aim starting with windows maybe you
have skype you can get skype to start
with windows
so i'm just going to scroll down and
drag drag tweet deck to the uh the start
menu uh the startup folder so just hover
over startup
and then drag it somewhere inside there
like a
so tweetdeck is now in the startup
folder so now whenever you start up your
computer tweetdeck will open up so if
you're wondering where it went that i
minimized it down here in the system
tray you see this little icon right here
double click it and tweetdeck opens up
so you now have tweetdeck you can
obviously tweet using a tweet button
right there
doing
recording a video hit the enter button
it sends your tweet out if you do uh on
the right hand side want to attach
facebook to this you can also that would
be your facebook status
if you have a url you want to share you
can post paste that url there shorten it
and then send your tweet uh you can also
attach a picture you can obviously
shrink the update if it's more than your
140 characters
but i basically this is just an
installation video so if you do want a
full review video i'm planning on
getting to that very soon
anyway this has been a brief tweet deck
installation tutorial i hope this was
helpful to you and if you're not already
following me on twitter the link is in
the description in this video and that's
basically it so thanks for watching
peace